le conseil général de la réunion vous
présente lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais
dans certaines familles la vieillesse le
handicap ou la maladie font
malheureusement partie du quotidien il
existe des établissements pour
accueillir et s'occuper de ces personnes
atteintes de ces pathologies
mais certaines familles font le choix de
ne pas placer leurs proches un choix
humain est respectable mais très
difficile à assumer au quotidien car
quand on a une personne à charge on est
obligé de mettre sa propre vie de côté
un sacrifice mal accompagné et très peu
soutenu les personnes aidantes doivent
dans la plupart des cas affronter seules
les difficultés de cette situation alors
qui peut apporter de l'aide à ces
personnes bénévoles peuvent-elles elles
aussi obtenir de l'aide et du soutien on
en parle maintenant d'un lien social
ghislaine habitent dans les eaux de bois
de nèfles à sainte clotilde à première
vue elle mène une vie normale et
ordinaire mais ghislaine n'a pas un
quotidien comme tout le monde
car elle s'occupe de sa maman malade un
choix qu'elle a fait il ya maintenant
neuf ans la maman de ghislaine est
atteinte de la maladie d'alzheimer et du
diabète ghislaine pourrait très bien
placé sa maman dans un établissement
spécialisé
mais pour elle ce serait une façon père
d'ordonner sa propre mère pour moi
c'était tout à fait logique
si vous voulez c'était logique de la
mesure où je suis sa fille et c'est ma
maman je ne voyais pas la mettre quelque
part la place et quelque part
j'essaye de faire c'est pas devoir
j'aime pas ce mot parce que c'est un
choix c'est un choix de vie que j'ai
fait j'aime pas ce mot parce qu'on me
dit oh fait son devoir on a l'impression
qu'on est obligé de le faire si on ne le
fait pas on culpabilise les gens disent
bon oui mais a fait son devoir c'est
tout à fait normal non c'est pas nous
voir j'aurais pu j'aurais pu la placer
quelque part mais c'est un choix d'
j'avais à choisir entre la place et
quelque part et la garder je préférais
la gare dit que c'est un choix c'est pas
un devoir
c'est vrai que ces sessions de charges
il faut pas faut pas le cacher et puis
voilà après j'essaye d'avoir toujours
des pieds dans la société faire des
choses à l'extérieur pour que je
supporte mieux la vie avec ma maman mais
c'est vrai que c'est une charge sais
c'est pas facile tous les jours il ya
des moments où il ya des bons moments
parce que moi moi je moi j'aime bien
quand maman elle m'appelle médian ma
chérie vient mon trésor et à
l'embrassade me prend dans ses bras et
c'est donc ça c'est extraordinaire mais
après aussi et à des moments
d'agressivité est là elle a oublié son
état voilà si c'est pas évident et c'est
vrai que cela c'est pénible même ces
voix là c'est pas évident tous les jours
malgré des moments difficiles ghislaine
assume très bien le fait de garder sa
maman elle le fait avec beaucoup d'amour
et de patience mais parfois certains
jours la charge est plus difficile à
accepter il ya un an et demi ghislaine a
appris l'existence du dispositif répit
repos ce système de répit repos ça
arrive bien parce que c'est depuis un an
et demi maintenant que j'ai découvert ça
c'est ça me permet de souffler 8 heures
par mois par sir toute une journée
avoir quelqu'un la confiance en la
personne qui vient le remplacer des fois
je l'a confié un ehpad
maximum trois semaines et là c'est vrai
que ça me permet de partir moi ça me
fait bizarre quand je m'en vais le matin
je fermais porter voilà quoi c'est la
vie et belge je suis libre voilà c'est
cette liberté là qui qui ment quand on a
une personne à charge de maladie
d'alzheimer etc le dispositif répit
repos c'est un accompagnement et une
évaluation des besoins à la personne
aidante une personne qualifiée vient au
domicile rencontrer la personne aidante
professionnelle dans le domaine l estime
et établit les besoins propose des
solutions pour que la personne concernée
puisse être soutenue et soulagés grâce
aux diverses aides et dispositifs
existants c'est le cas de antinéa
infirmières professionnels c'est elle
qui s'est occupé du cas de ghislaine et
sa maman ce qui m'a plu voilà déjà à
travers ce cet aspect en fait du métier
d'infirmière c'est de pouvoir rencontrer
des personnes comme adam besoin dans une
situation
compliquée que ce soit au niveau social
mais aussi aussi au niveau sanitaire et
pouvoir apporter on va dire une écoute
pour y permettre déjà la reconnaissance
de son statut des lentes donc la
première chose qui est intéressant dans
le cadre de notre travail c'est vraiment
de rencontrer ces personnes à leur
domicile dans leur quotidien avec leur
réalité et donc à travers ça de pouvoir
évaluer leur sac subissent leur
situation essayez de comprendre leur
situation son pouvoir amener une réponse
et une orientation éventuelle par le
biais donc dans le cadre donc j'ai
dispositif aurait piropo par le biais du
ray piropo donc notre travail au
quotidien
c'est vraiment de rencontrer les élans
au domicile et leur proposer cet
accompagnement la cette orientation
en fonction vraiment de leurs besoins
le dispositif répit repos est une
initiative entièrement financé par le
conseil général
comme beaucoup de dispositifs mis en
place par le département répit repos
apporte un soutien et une aide aux
personnes qui en ont le plus besoin oui
le dispositif et piropo est un
dispositif innovant mise en place par le
conseil général mais gérée par le gp
maison des dallas personnes dont le but
est de prendre en compte la situation de
quelque 45000 aidants familiaux qui
existe à la réunion qui sont des
personnes remarquables
parce qu'elles aident quotidiennement
jour et nuit des membres de la famille
ou des proches ou des voisins elle les
aide bénévolement pour les accompagner
dans leurs actes de la vie quotidienne
parce que ces personnes soient sorte
qu'après soit très âgées cet état
d'aidant familial est remarquable mais
il injurie de la part de ces recettes
puis ces personnes aidantes d état de
grande fatigue des ehdaa des états
parfois des compréhensions parce que la
société ne reconnaît pas le rôle
fondamental qu'il joue et la présente
conseil général a souhaité offrir à ces
personnes des phases de retiro peau qui
consiste tout simplement à leur offrir
des périodes de week-end ou deux
journées où elle se reposait se
déconnecte de cet acte d' accompagnement
quotidien qui parfois est l'horizon
grâce à ray piropo ghislaine continue de
s'occuper de sa maman avec autant
d'amour et de patience mais peut
également s'accorder un peu de temps
pour elle si vous souhaitez vous aussi
pouvoir en bénéficier l'an prochain
appelez le 0 800 53 00 02 et faites vous
connaître auprès de la maison des aides
à la personne le conseil général de la
réunion vous a présenté lien social le
conseil général aux côtés des
réunionnais